bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver et sur public sénat
tout au long du mois de septembre et
bien je vous propose de voir et de
revoir les temps forts des auditions et
de la séance lors de la dernière session
parlementaire car tout au long du mois
de septembre est bien les sénateurs sont
absents du palais du luxembourg car ils
sont en campagne il prépare les
prochaines élections sénatoriales qui se
tiendront le 28 septembre et qui
permettront de renouveler la moitié de
la haute assemblée retour aujourd'hui à
une audition qui s'est tenue le 9 avril
dernier au sénat une audition de thierry
breton ancien ministre de l'économie par
la mission commune d'information sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet
l'ancien ministre est aujourd'hui
président d'atos l'un des leaders de
l'informatique au niveau mondial et à ce
titre il s'était vu confier deux
missions l'une par la commission
européenne et l'autre par arnaud
montebourg alors que lui même était
encore ministre de mission portant sur
l'internet dématérialiser le fameux
cloud cet espace virtuel de stockage sur
internet ils avaient d'ailleurs livré
certaines de ses conclusions au sénat le
9 avril on les écoute madame monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que je
suis très honoré trouver dans cette
salle
ok je suis aller sous d'autres avec
d'autres responsabilités
et vous dire aussi que le sujet que vous
traitez nous le rapporteur est un sujet
qui me semble absolument essentiel pour
pour la nation mais aussi vous l'avez
rappelé dans vos propos pur pour
l'europe alors c'est un sujet sur lequel
on travaille depuis très longtemps et
j'ai travaillé moyenne depuis très
longtemps dans le cadre de mes
différentes fonctions précédentes pardon
un petit aparté au début avec eux autres
collègues sénateurs anneaux mais nous
nous rappelions que en 1993
président a noté venu me demander de
contribuer à la définition pédagogique
des enseignements l'ingénieur du futur
cas de l'université de technologie de
troyes
d'où la petite aparté et pour dire que
les sujets que vous que vous traitez
sont absolument essentielles et au coeur
aussi de mes préoccupations personnelles
si vous permettez un petit point un
petit point également pour vous pour
vous dire
j'ai évidemment accepté avec
enthousiasme quand on m'a proposé de
venir aujourd'hui
j'ai j'ai trouvé que le titre que
nouveau rôle et nouvelle stratégie pour
l'union européenne dans la gouvernance
mondiale de l'internet
était pour moi pardon de le dire comme
ça mais un peu réducteur par rapport à
l'ambition que je crois déceler derrière
vos propos liminaire parce qu'au fond
qu'est ce que sera l'internet dans cinq
ans dans dix ans est-ce qu'il existera
encore est ce que le terme même existera
on se rappeler que quand on a démarré
avec philippe ando savoir une formation
du futur le mot n'existait pas encore au
mois peine dans l'internet c'est un
protocole qui permet effectivement des
échanges de données de plus en plus
rapide
destockage
le sentiment moi qui m'anime est
ce que j'ai essayé d'apporter dans les
deux contributions qu'elle vous faites
allusion c'est bien d'être d'au-delà
d'internet internet aujourd'hui tu as la
main essentiellement de
nos amis américains
on voit effectivement
y avoir un rôle mondial peut-être le
vrai sujet pour moi si vous permettez
c'est le sujet des données car au fond
d'un net permet de véhiculer des données
de les stocker de les pros ccc ça à mon
avis la réflexion de long terme qu'il
faut je crois avoir pour notre pays et
pour l'honneur et pour l'europe les
protocoles c'est comme si on lorsque
j'ai des prix dans thomson on m'avait
demandé d'assister à une audition sur
quel est l'avenir
de mp3
coordination de mp3 voilà donc je pars
donc un peu réducteur mais
volontairement ça je ne serais pas là et
je crois vraiment que le sujet quitte
absolument essentiel pour
pour nous et pour nos compatriotes c'est
vraiment le sujet des données de données
on le dit de façon un peu caricaturale
pardon de le dire comme ça mais c'est ma
conviction c'est l'heure numérique c'est
l'or noir de demain c'est la richesse de
demain
ces données vous avez entendu des tas de
personnes qui me l'ont dit vous le savez
par ailleurs
tous les 18 mois
l'activité humaine génère plus de
données que on en a généré depuis la
nuit des temps jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc 7,7 caractère
exponentiel de la génération des données
la nécessité également leur traitement
leur capsule de stockage en traitement
et puis derrière vous avez effectivement
tout ce qui va autour
en termes de création de richesses
d'innovation les algorithmes qui vont
permettre de les traiter le profiling
pour les individus etc etc atika donc on
le voit nous mêmes du reste de nos
activités ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
le véritable moteur de l'innovation le
véritable moteur de l'innovation c'est
dans cette économie numérique qui
s'annonce c'est la proximité de ces
données permettent finalement de donner
un usage à l'accès à ces données à
toutes les start up aux innovateurs à
tous ceux qui vont vouloir précisément
offrir des nouveaux services à valeur
ajoutée pour nos compatriotes pour nos
concitoyens mais aussi pour les
entreprises et cette proximité
cet accès est absolument essentielle et
c'est vrai il ya une différence avoir un
accès à des données qui sont localisés
ils ont dans un environnement qui vous
est proche ou donné qu'ils sont de
localiser ailleurs
dans d'autres environnements avec
d'autres régulation d'autres éléments de
contrôle et on y revient on revient
exactement sur ce sujet
qui pour moi va vraiment animé dans le
cadre alors si vous permettez je vais
commencer à parler d'eux s'ils ont donc
que je mène avec jim chien peut qu est
le coprésident de sf de la sape et puis
ensuite celle que m'a confié le ministre
donc de l'économie d'entassement
productif et du numérique sur sur
le cloud enfants en france et la façon
de le dynamiser et de permettre son son
essor
d'abord avec un avec mon collègue co
président de s&p nous avons été fait
partie d'un
open cloud partnership pardon de
l'anglicisme on ne rapporte pas
l'anglais donc c'est le sait le board
donc qui réunit
hubert tardieu qui m'accompagne
suisse et à faire pour moi à bruxelles
une trentaine de participants dont une
entreprise pardon je vous ai pas
présenté mais deux et deux
collaborateurs dont gilbert tardieux
donc qui est le patron la communauté
scientifique chez atos qui vire tout
nous tous nos pays riches dit elle aux
scientifiques et les vécus ni qui après
avoir été directeur de cabinet d'un
président de l'assemblée qui n'était pas
le sénat et maintenant mon directeur de
cabinet
au sein d'atos et suit notamment les
aspects qu'on a développée avec
monsieur montebourg est ce que là bas
qui est le co
président de la mission sur le cloud
donc avec hubert tardieu effectivement
on a on a en a on a vraiment essayé de
de travailler avec nos collègues
européens donc à l'initiative des délits
crous sur 7 sur cette affaire et en
essayant de définir un générer un cadre
à cadre
européens et sur d'appel ça on a appelé
ça entre nous un espace de confiance
pour pour permettre au cloud de se
développer vers le cloud évidemment il
ya l'aspect des données alors on a
commencé par dire qu'il ya quelque chose
d'assez simple on a et on essaie
vraiment de développer cette c'était cet
état d'esprit au fond c'est les données
des européens doivent être stockés
traité procès c'est en europe on est
ouverts raconte y trouvèrent on peut
accepter que l'on vient de les traiter
les poux conviennent anticiper à ce
traitement est processing si certains
ont des des innovations technologiques
pour accroître les capacités de stockage
ont deux algorithmes sophistiqués pour
permettre de les mettre en cohérence
très bien on est ouvert il faut que
l'europe est un continent qui t'a
continent qui doit être ouvert aux
innovations aux investissements mais il
ya une chose qui doit être certaine il a
je pense que là dessus ne faut pas
transiger nous donner nous appartiennent
et on en a même la responsabilité
donc c'est quelque chose de simple on a
utilisé du reste cette cette notion un
peu ensuite avec nos collègues y en a il
faudrait un peu une politique de petits
pas comme on a développé lors de la mise
en oeuvre de schengen c'est à dire des
pays qui adoptent un 2/3 des pays
pionniers une même approche
et n'ayons pas peur des mots régulatrice
de la façon dont on traite houston nous
donner et puis voilà si jamais notre
rêve au fond on a vu président hollande
parle et on doit voir madame merkel si
l'allemagne et la france adopte une
approche identique pense que ça va faire
des émules et que de deux trois quatre
pays vont peut-être avoir la même
approche en ce qui concerne donc cet
aspect des choses on veut surtout pas
lors des bd veille on avait démarré du
reste notre réflexion avant même que les
révélations de l'été dernier
donne parle évidemment des révélations
de monsieur snowdon donne un angle plus
particulier donc sur les données
beaucoup s'en sont émus
mais il est clair que nous avions
démarré notre réflexion et notre action
ou bien avant ça on n'est pas du tout
dans une dans une logique où on essaie
de réagir par rapport à des événements
on pense que c'est notre responsabilité
c'est la responsabilité des
représentants
peuple que vous n'êtes que de ce
vraiment les législateurs de se
préoccuper de cette question et d'avoir
d'avoir quelques quelques idées peut
être simple mais mais mais assez ferme
au fond est-ce qu'on imaginerait que
les données essentielles des chinois
soient traitées en dehors de chine
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce serait est-ce
qu'on imaginerait que les données
financières des américains ou de données
d'impôt de america soit traité en france
en belgique ou wire donc il ya des pays
qui ont des réactions assez clair dessus
et puis il ya un continent qui est un
peu plus le manque de coordination qui
prend un peu de temps or il faut aller
vite
quand on regarde l'évolution de façon
dont
la richesse économique s'est créé au
cours des cours des siècles
on a commencé par traiter l'espace
territorial et puis on a régulé l'espace
territorial pour mieux le réglementer
créer des richesses étaient partagés
après ça ça a été l'espace r il ya
l'espace maritime
et puis l'espace aérien est désormais
c'est désormais c'est l'espace
informationnel il faut aussi en prendre
possession il faut aussi avoir le
courage de le réglementer pas trop en
tout cas d'avoir des règles communes et
ça c'est la première d'entre elles donc
on est vraiment là dessus vraiment on
voudrait avoir art les suis ouvert
évidemment pouvoirs publics français on
a eu un peu de mal au début les aligner
mais je dois dire que après quelques
quelques quelques périodes qui était un
peu erratique on a maintenant un bon
alignement des positions françaises voir
les français quand hubert avec les
positions tous des positions de défendre
au niveau de l'europe dans le cadre
encore une fois de cette de cette
commission
donc je le répète première chose essayer
de faire en sorte que nous créions un
espace de confiance
donc au niveau d'aidé des pays qui
voudraient qu'ils voudraient adopter
cette approche
une deuxième chose c'est évidemment le
fait que la protection de ces données
ne doit pas être je dirais une façon
unique mais au contraire adapté à leur
nature et leur usage des données qui
sont faites sans importance il a
d'autres dont on estime qu'elles sont
plus importantes
l'e santé l'e qui correspondent à son
patrimoine fiscalité
ce qui concerne le secteur veut le
secteur financier et bancaire
se rappelle que vous allez avoir une
échéance importante avec l'évolution de
swift 2015 on était parfaitement au
courant de ça j'imagine
donc donc on a en a qu'on a défini un
certain nombre voilà des données on hamm
est bronze silver gold jeremy en a qui
sont moins importantes que d'autres on
peut il se permettre on peut
éventuellement il sait pas de problème
qu'elle soit parce que finalement vos
consommations de musique vos morceaux de
musique préférés à ce que ça peut être
été dans le serveur du nebraska
peut-être
les de santé peut-être pas donc voilà il
faut quand même qu'on est là dessus
quelque chose
une approche donc on a segmenté de façon
assez simple et puis en faisant en sorte
qu'on se positionne le dernier élément
qui est important c'est celle éléments
de la confiance on le voit aujourd'hui
notamment après la révélation de l'été
dernier beaucoup d'entreprises acteurs
et acteurs économiques voire de
gouvernement hésite un peu à passer en
mode cloud le cloud c'est évidemment une
évolution très importante puisque ça
permet la mutualisation de
l'infrastructure informatique des
capacités de stockage la virtualisation
ensuite qui est associé donc pour
pouvoir étaient sûrs d'eux-mêmes fermes
de serveurs
des applications différentes pour des
clients différents et donc de réduire
les coûts très sensiblement d'augmenter
la capacité traitement la réalité de
stockage et puis surtout de passer en
paiement à l usage qui est extrêmement
important et non plus de faire en
supportés par les clients les
investisseurs les les autres les
entreprises ou les gouvernements ou les
collectivités locales le poids de
l'investissement mais évident de passer
en pay per use c'est dément l usage sur
la zone instance a posé plein de
questions de tva quand on applique sans
suite à l'enfant en france par rapport
aux dépenses d'investissement et aux
dépenses de fonctionnement mais j'aime
bien dans un instant donc sur le niveau
européen sur cette question des choses
de cette question on se rend compte
qu'il ya eu un peu de réticence et fond
il faut aller vite la compétitivité
passe aussi beaucoup beaucoup par sly de
plus en plus part cela le fait qu'on ait
des dd système qui soit pas harmonisée
des différences de régulation entre la
france entre l'allemagne entre la
belgique luxembourg et autres on voit
bien par exemple que nous ne pouvons pas
traiter aujourd'hui pas voir on est un
groupe européen par les atos tout
donc on est présent dans tous les pays
européens on est amené le leader en
europe on m'a si on veut faire
bénéficier nos clients de des
infrastructures de cloud par exemple et
même des clients gouvernementaux part on
peut pas sur des données même simple il
faut qu'on ait des serveurs d'à côté du
real c'est vrai l'autre côté du rhin on
peut pas des pannes harmonisation ça
aussi c'est un manque de compétitivité
au fond on se rend bien compte que que
quand on dit qu'il faut qu'il nous faut
on complète pour un espace de confiance
niveau européen avec des qualités de
sécurité
des services on appelle ça en anglais ds
le service level agreements est à dire d
comme on peut dire ça en français niveau
de ces risques de niveau service garanti
donc qu'ils sont qui sont précisés pour
pouvoir on dit également que au fond
devenir opérateur de données en termes
de capacité de stockage de traitement de
et de l'est le processing de ces données
c'est pas ne s'est pas une fonction
anodine et donc nous on plaide pour
avoir une sorte de licence pour le faire
voilà c'est pas anodin de traiter les
données de ses compatriotes c'est
quelque chose voilà il faut il faut une
licence je crois pour un débit de
boissons une chose que d'avoir une
licence pour un traitement de données se
serait pas complètement
surréaliste que le demander et ça c'est
quelque chose et donc encore au niveau
repères si deux trois quatre pays
adoptent ce même ces mêmes niveaux de
service minimum pour pouvoir opérer des
fermes de serveurs en mode cloud par
exemple ça serait un plus très important
voilà donc
et nous demandons du reste si 1/3 de
contrôle effectif que vous ferez sans
peut accueillir n'importe qui et on va
oublier le patriot act et autre chose on
peut accueillir n'importe qui je pense
pouvoir traiter ces données mais si vous
venez les traités sur le territoire
européen il faut peut-être quelque part
avant une sorte de permis de conduire
pour le faire c'est à dire on applique
la loi européenne et pas d'autres lois
ah oui mais ça ne dépend que nous ça ne
dépend que de nous
moi je suis dans son pays européenne
j'ai beaucoup clients qui viennent me
voir parce que je suis entreprises
européennes vous comprenez parfaitement
ce que je veux dire donc ça ne dépend
que de nous c'est il faut qu'on impose
que voilà quand on traite des données en
europe c'est la loi européenne
ces deux lois françaises l'athée largy
ce serait l'idéal est libre à deux trois
quatre pays qui adoptent le même type de
régulation sur ces données qui
s'applique et aucune autre et on sait
qu'à ce moment là mais donné qu'en cd
confie c'est l'espace de confiance quand
je les confie je sais qu'elles sont
dépendent une voie que je connais et
donc j'accepte d'autant mieux de les
confier en confiance
c'est un sujet qui est absolument
essentiel 1 et l or on voit évidemment
que quand on discute de tout cela
les uns et les autres ont des approches
différentes
les lobbys des approches différentes je
pense que là il faut il faut essayer
d'être d'être fermé c'est vraiment
maintenant ou qui convient le faire
évidemment dans cette dans cette
approche le franco-allemand est
absolument essentiel nous avons vu nos
amis allemands depuis l'été dernier sera
fermé un peu sur eux mêmes donc je pense
qu'il est important d'être à
l'initiative viala vraiment un accès à
mon avis de coopération franco-allemande
est absolument essentiel et si nous
adoptions qui vont dire une approche à
peu près similaire ensemble ce serait un
très grand pas qui pourrait faire mon
avis assez rapidement
et qui ont la vue hubert qui permettrait
à d'autres de suivent ensuite ils nous
ont dit très clairement le couple
franco-allemand ici à mon avis pourrait
être un élément moteur dans cette danse
est
je dirais régulation l'espace de 2 0
points très ouvert évidemment nous avons
ouvert on n'est pas naïf on pourra pas
mettre des lignes maginot c'est pal
c'est pas la question la question c'est
encore une fois de dire que nos données
doivent être traitées procès en novembre
n'importe où sont les régulations simple
identique pour tous avec des mêmes
niveaux de sécurité je résume et bien
sûr j'aurai des questions reçues
répondre à vos questions si vous le
souhaitez entendu sur cette synthèse des
choses on a bien avancé on a remises
maintenant rapporte quasiment finalisé
hubert analyser et
en en consultation publique maintenant
sur sur ces aspects mais il faut que
vous sachiez que par notre présence il
celle du berck et à mes côtés la france
a été très moteur dans cette affaire
très moteur n'a été vraiment très très
moteur et et on a je crois un finalement
réussi à
entraîner un peu l'ensemble de nos deux
des parties prenantes qui étaient avec
nous il y compris nos amis britanniques
avec avec difficulté les miens landais
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais enfin
voilà il ya en tout cas en europe
continentale clairement une position une
position à jouer je pense que là il
serait formidable que les autorités
publiques et politiques de notre pays
s'en empare désormais
les industriels que nous sommes seront
derrière évidemment
voilà pour le
lion panne cloud partnership est donc la
publication du document de travail donc
qui a été réalisée le 21 mars 2014 et
qui sera vos dispositions évidemment je
pense que vos services en utilisant
l'accès donc on sera à votre disposition
pour le commenter répondre à vos
questions si vous le souhaitez
maintenant ce qui concerne la deuxième
aspect des choses c'était intéressant
parce qu'on a fait des approches
pratiquement parallèle donc on a pu lui
reste avant une bonne harmonie donc sur
le sur le cloud que m'avait confié par
nous et le monde nous envoie comme avec
le président de dow vh taf klaba donc là
on a fait une approche donc c'est
évidemment comment faire dans le cadre
des trente quatre plans de la nouvelle
france industrielle comment faire pour
pour dynamiser
le cloud évidemment avec la proche à la
fois d'innovations industrielles et
d'emploi puisque c'est un peu le
triptyque qui anime donc
arnaud montebourg dans son dans sa
volonté de
développer ses 34 plan pour la nouvelle
france industrielle
voilà donc donc on a travaillé avec une
très large consultation donc de
l'ensemble des acteurs français un
travail important là qui était plutôt
mené par orly par olivier qui a piloté
ce a donc
fait tout ça à bercy
ça nous demander beaucoup de temps
un très bon niveau de coordination et on
a maintenant un document qui est
finalisé on a remis leur espace janvier
je crois qu'il n'est pas encore
publiquement faveur je pense qu'il n'y
aura aucun problème pour que vous en
ayez connaissance je pense qu'on
communiqué
qu'il ya ya ya ya pas de problème et
vous verrez que ce ont ce document est
là c'est assez exhaustif je vais le
résumé donc d'une part en ce qui
concerne donc l'homme là aussi redonner
confiance
donc pour permettre à l'ensemble des
entreprises françaises aussi des agents
économiques de plus en plus de faire
appel au cloud
donc une labellisation
secure cloud c'est à dire faire en sorte
que
là encore lorsque on opère en mode cloud
sur territoire français c'est le pendant
de ce que je disais au niveau européen
on a un niveau de labellisation et 7 je
dirais que
l'équipe n'a permis de la permis
d'opérer avec façon à ce qu'on est on
est vraiment cet élément de confiance
qui est absolument essentiel pour
pouvoir passer en mode cloud et faire en
sorte qu'un acteur économique un agent
économique confie ses données le
traitement de ces données à un tiers il
faut 7 il faut que ce tiers soit tiers
de confiance donc il faut qu'on ait
quand même un certain nombre d'éléments
nous avons assisté aussi sur le
développement de dab store
d'applications pour les collectivités
locales un peu à l'image de ce que ce
qu'elle fait avec un certain succès le
gouvernement britannique avec le g cloud
donc on pense que c'est un très bon
escient pour nous un très très grand
acteur
là des premières en grande bretagne on
travaille énormément avec le
gouvernement britannique tous et toutes
ses admirations et on a contribué à
mettre beaucoup de ces applications donc
en ligne pour les collectivités locales
britanniques on pense que là il ya un
champ tout à fait intéressant on va
rentrer dans un dans un période
évidemment de vous essayer de faire de
l'économie tout en continuant à
augmenter la qualité de service que les
services publics il ya là un jeu un jeu
formidable on le commence à faire un peu
il ya des régions comme la région
bourgogne on travaille à l'autre on
développe des app store bon là on le
fait pour l'un c'est quand même
formidable qu'on puisse le faire sur
tout le monde et la capacité de du cloud
à nous permet de le faire je dirais à
moindre coût quasiment en temps réel et
sans supporter le coût d'investissement
donc tout à fait
important pour les collectivités locales
même si
on avait on avait identifié évidemment
mais si on parle pas que le fait de
passer en cloud notamment pour la
gestion de collectivités locales avec
des dix applications qui sont quasiment
fait
ils apprennent de tva parce
qu'évidemment on veut tant
d'investissements pour la récupérer et
quand vous êtes en fonctionnement vous
l'a récupéré pas et nous on aime bien
sûr maintenant que la danse
fonctionnement donc il ya un petit sujet
qu'il faut vraiment traité qui est un
frein est du reste été rime pas ce que
vous avez même des collectivités qui
nous disent on va fort bien mais c'est
faire des économies mais
là là je récupère la tva donc ça
m'intéresse plus voilà donc on voit que
notre système fiscal n'est pas incitatif
aller dans une solution qui est ce qui
permet de réaliser des économies qu il
ya peut-être quelque chose là même
quelque chose en forme a signalé un mais
je vous le dis parce que évidemment tu
connais un petit peu bercy également
avoir quelques réticences c'est un
combat à mon avis qui me semble être un
combat bon combat à mener pour nous pour
nos économies est pour et pour les les
collectivités locales ont la filiale air
dur et ça c'est quelque chose qui figure
à notre rapport voilà donc
sur sur le
passé mon temps question assez juste
juste dire qu'on a on a également
défini donc
à tout un écosystème des critères pour
que l'écosystème seraient favorables au
niveau du cloud les problèmes aussi de
l'investissement les opérer une des
plates formes de cloud cité c'est très
consommateurs d'énergie c'est un peu
électro intensifs donc donc on a il ya
sans doute des choses à faire là aussi
et la france a été pendant longtemps
impliqué très attractif en matière
énergétique notamment par rapport à
cette politique nucléaire grâce à sa
politique nucléaire
il nous faut il faut
on commence à voir que autour des
centrales nucléaires il ya certainement
des choses à faire pour pouvoir avoir
des lieux privilégiés de de traitement
de données en mode cloud ça consomme
énormément d'énergie qu'un rappel c'est
des plateformes comme des plates formes
d' amazon ou google c'est débile de
10000 habitants consommation donc c'est
débile ccc des éléments très importants
bon il ya besoin d'avoir une continuité
et une qualité de courant une très bonne
qualité de courant sans saute c'est
effectivement ce que permet notre parc
nucléaire français
on peut avoir de bonnes prévisions du
prix des qualités évidemment par
définition linéaire et s'implique donc
s'est parfaitement adapté donc on a
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec le le
patrimoine nucléaire qui est le nôtre on
a certainement une carte à jouer très
intéressante par rapport à d'autres pays
ils sont soumis y compris dans des
énergies des énergies renouvelables qui
donne pas la même qualité de courant qui
n'ont pas les mêmes la prédictibilité
pour ce type d'activité donc c'est une
carte alors on verra si fier on sera
toujours comme ça dans 50 ans mais en
tout cas pour les dix ou vingt ans qui
viennent je pense que l'on sera toujours
1 50% au moins de production d'autres
courants électriques en nucléaire il ya
certainement une carte à jouer et je
pense que là aussi mais qu'on l'a vu
aussi en matière de réindustralisation
comme dans d'autres un autre sujet avec
peut-être la possibilité d'avoir une
une
des tarifs des tarifs qui permettent
d'attirer ce type de ce type d'activité
voilà on a aussi des filiales et les
choses comme les plates formes tremplin
à destination des éditeurs de logiciels
c'est important effectivement on a une
bonne activité d'éditeur de logiciels en
france mais cannes relativement petit il
faut les aider à migrer sur le cloud il
faudra sans doute
intervenir pour pouvoir les aider dans
cette migration peut-être financièrement
trouver des poux il faut trouver des
moyens des moyens intéressants pour
pouvoir précisément leur permettre la
loi de bénéficier à la capacité
démultiplier de distribution en passant
en mode cloud mais là ils sont infinies
sont un peu réticents pour le faire
parce que c'est des investissements qui
sont assez importants je pense que
l'état pourrait là pourrait jouer un
rôle peut être intéressant important
dans cette transition
j'ai résumé un peu rapidement je m'en
excuse mais voilà les deux volets sur
lesquels nous travaillons et nous vous
remercions nous allons vous poser
forcément quelques questions en
complément s'agissant des données vous
nous avez vu un petit peu réagir parce
que forcément c'est au coeur de notre
réflexion c'est d'ailleurs un sujet que
nous avions évoqués ya plus d'un an dans
la commission des affaires européennes
et comme vous nous n'avons pas attendu
la ferme moderne pour nous préoccuper de
cette question qui me semblait
éminemment
stratégique s'agissant de la protection
des données comment peut-on assurer un
service sécurisé du cloud donc l'europe
ne maîtrise pas tout la pile matérielles
et logicielles qui soutient ce service
saas une première question nous avons la
deuxième question elle résulte de la
symétrie qu'il existe entre nos
juridictions européennes et américaines
et la mamie ce que peuvent avoir les
états unis sur des données il comprit
stockées en en europe
de ce point de vue comment analysez-vous
le projet de règlement européen sur
lequel il ya encore beaucoup de
discussions est ce que vous pourriez
nous nous en donner une appréciation par
rapport aux objectifs que vous vous
mettez légitimement en avant il répond
t-il justement à cette à cet objectif
pour la première c'est une question sur
les données se fera que c'est une
question importante
de la question qui a monté la première
fois vous faites référence directement
au patriot act en fait et
alors qui est un sujet moi je vous le
dis en tant qu'
on va laisser aux acteurs publics le
soin de s'exprimer cette question je ne
suis plus un acteur public donc je vais
exprimer en tant que que chef
d'entreprise et est
également en tant que prestataire de
traitement de données pour le compte de
mes clients je vous direz vous dire que
là pour le coup là sujet qui qui qui
passe sans cesse croissant il ya une
préoccupation maintenant systématique
systématique de la part de nos clients
européens sur cette question lire
d'abord pour eux leur propre patrimoine
informationnel applicatifs
leur proposer leurs propres informations
mais aussi pour beaucoup d'entre eux
l'ont fait en responsabilité vis-à-vis
de leurs clients et pas uniquement du
secteur bancaire bien sûr le secteur
bancaire mais également l'autre et donc
on est on est un terrain nous sommes
interrogés
quasiment systématiquement maintenant
sur les relations on avoir sur le risque
que cette législation particulière peut
faire courir et puis sur leurs propres
responsabilités
par rapport à l'or à leurs propres
clients on prend l'exemple du secteur
bancaire
voilà il ya un secret bancaire d certain
nombre de garanties vous êtes couverts
par une voix qui connut cette
dérégulation qui est connu et aux opérés
et puis on veut savoir ce qui peut se
passer donc cette question d'une
question absolument essentiel et je
crois qu'il est absolument indispensable
que l'union européenne prenne une
position ferme sur cette question donc
voilà je trouve qu'on n'est pas encore
assez ferme bref on aurait clairement à
votre question je pense que c'est un
sujet qui va devenir absolument
essentiel alors nos amis américains en
sont conscients
je pense qu'il commence à
se dire qu'il va sans doute falloir
évoluer les choses je pense que la
période est favorable pour avoir ouvrir
une discussion bilatérale avec eux sur
cette question
mais là aussi
il serait à mon avis absolument
essentiel d'arrivée d'arrivée groupée
et je le redis je suis un peu inquiet de
voir que depuis quelques mois
l'allemagne fait un peu cavalier seul
sur ces questions
donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
je le redis une nécessité d'un
croisement de deux des relations
franco-allemandes sur cette question est
qui va pour moi bien au delà et c'est
pour ça que je me suis permis de cette
petite digression au début
mes propos qui va au delà de l'internet
où l'intérêt d'internet européens
l'internet franco allemand ou que
sais-je je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet qui est beaucoup plus profond que
cela et qui dépasse de beaucoup le
simple cadre de l'internet voilà donc là
je pense qu'on n'est pas encore on n'est
pas encore assez
justement nous avons rencontré tous nos
homologues
au bundestag à berlin discret bien
conscience de l'importance de cet axe
franco allemand ils sont dans une même
réflexion
évoquant justement l'allemagne comment
avez vous compris l'appel de madame
merkel à la constitution d'un internet
européen je pense qu'il ya deux choses
il ya d'abord le stockage via les flux
alors sur le stockage ce nom dont on
parle
et
pour des raisons sans doute historique
l'allemagne compte tenu de son histoire
récente en particulier et à une relation
très
j'allais dire passionnée et passionnelle
problème de la protection des données
voilà et donc
ça publiquement mais
je pense que madame merkel en
particulier elle aussi voilà donc il
fallait voilà moi j'ai perçu ça que
j'allais voir une réponse un peu
politique c'est un peu de tes sources
qui nous gêne là parce que
comme le rappelait tout à l'heure vous
avez démarré cette réflexion avance nous
donne donne est arrivé c'est dans une
autre connotation on n'est pas en mode
on n'est pas en mode de réaction on est
on est tout simplement parce qu'on fait
notre travail les uns et les autres dans
ce fameux quatrième espace vous allez
avoir à le réguler comme vous réguler
législateurs des trois premiers cas
d'espèce il ya des sénateurs spécialiste
du droit maritime je pense qu'elle sp
civil droit et rien du médiateur
dessinatrice pays le droit et rien
falloir qu'ils les spécialistes du droit
informationnelle et pas internet
informationnel c'est ça le nouveau 2
donc il va falloir regarder et
et en allemagne ben on a répondu un peu
les élections c'était à une réponse qui
est un peu politique et enfin c'est
comme ça que j'ai ressenti alors ceci
dit c'est parfaitement faisable
on peut avoir
des skis concerne la gestion des flux
donc et donc l'internet aujourd'hui qui
le gère qui leur est dû qu il régule et
on préfère appeler sa gestion des flux
chez nous parce que encore une fois il
est allé aux nouvelles qui vont arriver
plutôt qu'internet la gestion des flux
avec les routeurs et les opérateurs
télécoms j'ai été dans ma jeunesse
président france télécom également donc
je connais un petit sujet voilà on peut
on peut fonds pourrait très bien faire
comme le font les américains du reste
que le fond du chinois par ailleurs
c'est-à-dire demandé à ce que les
routeurs soit localisée sur le
territoire européen et qu'il incombe aux
règles européennes font les routeurs
américains et sont localisées sur le
territoire américain je prendrai être
utilisé ailleurs bon bah voilà c'est ça
l'internet européen il suffit de dire ça
si vous dites ça vous avez répondu à
l'internet européen
que les routeurs
mais non même les routeurs chinois il
faut vérifier si vous faites référence
je vois que madame madame et connaît
bien oui oui vous avez voilà oui mais
enfin
on n'en revient la question du patriot
act
ou son équivalent de notre côté - moi
moins visibles mais voilà en tout cas
que c'est que c'est que ces
sites c'est curieux parce que on est
dans un monde qui est totalement
délocalisée
globalisé et dématérialisés enfin pour
les données la territorialité que ce
soit pour le stockage ou pour le flux
bah ça existe et il y aura pas d'autre
solution je pense qu'il faut avoir la
force de le dire et de ne pas apparaître
du reste comme des
rétrogrades il suffit de faire
continent de 565 millions d'habitants on
fait comme lefebvre continent 2
380 ou à un autre de 1 milliard voilà on
fait la même chose pour nos propres
concitoyens compatriotes
ça c'était pour la première la deuxième
question et quant à la première pardon
je vais
le projet de règlement mais je crois que
c'est ce que vous avez
évoquerez et puis oui c'était
le fait que pour l'instant l'europe ne
nous semble pas maîtriser toute la pile
matérielles et logicielles que
constituent les services du cloud voilà
comment on va résoudre cette question
oui bah bah ça c'est
vous avez
aujourd'hui
les routeurs de vienne puis ce n'est pas
tout à l'heure de biens des ce qu'on
appelle en anglais des commodities
pratiquement assez dans le monde où la
leur qui sera pas brillant auteur de
mars rien
de plus en plus d'entreprises chinoises
c'est vrai on en a encore une ou deux en
or à petit qu'il reste mais
moi je pars d'un principe ou
les technologies à qu'elles soient du
reste au niveau applicatif couches
logicielles ou matérielles
sont
ce qu'elles sont il faut pour pouvoir
les utiliser sur un territoire donné
demandé à ce qu'elle répond dans un
certain nombre de normes et puis après
ça on regarde ce qui se passe et de
contrôle plutôt que de dire on va
interdire les routeurs chinois on va
interdire les routeurs je ne sais quoi
parce qu'on fait finalement un
procès d'intention à priori ben si si
vous mettez en europe voilà et puis si
jamais on se rend compte que ben voilà
ce que vous encourez je pense que là il
faut on pourra on a besoin de
technologies et tout le monde doit la
technologie elle est ouverte et les
mondiale alors on va pas se recréer les
technologies j'ai eu à gérer dans ma
carrière la fin du plan calcul c'était
dur au nom d'une indépendance
voilà on gère des situations qui sont
absolument intenable il vaut mieux
être un espace qui est moderne réguler
ouvert mais avec une régulation assez
clair assez forte et puis que l'on
l'utilisent pour mieux ensuite contrôlés
que ceux qui vont vouloir opérer on les
force pas un mais si vous venez
installez vos systèmes chez nous voilà
ce que ils doivent permettre de faire et
voilà ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire et
derrière on découvre toujours toujours
découvrir six fils qui se passe donc je
préfère avoir un contrôle a priori
et a posteriori pardon que que que de
dire que d'avoir fait un procès
d'intention a priori parce que
finalement
ça c'est la compétitivité dans un monde
ouvert et le monde et les technologies
de l'information est un monde ouvert
de territoires qu'ils vont appliquer on
peut appliquer ce type de ce type
d'après ce qui va en pâtir tout de suite
on est obligé effectivement d'accepter
les technologies du monde entier on est
aussi
oublié de ne pas naïf j'ai d'avoir des
régulations qui vont bien
quel bilan vous tirer du grand emprunt
dans son financement des deux projets de
classe de français savoir qu la droite
et énergie et puis peut-être une autre
question
vous avez dit que notre industrie des
télécoms brûlé et que nous regardions
ailleurs donc
concrètement beaucoup d'ennemis quelles
seraient les grands axes voilà d'une
politique aujourd'hui efficace pour
reprendre un peu la main sur ces sujets
bon sur le grand emprunt
et sur les c'est trop tôt pour en parler
parce qu'ils ont les olives donne de
démarrer je crois qu'ils ont encore un
nombre assez limité de clients aussi
bien on a vu
pour pas de porte pas de jugement mais
ça part un peu mais enfin c'est quand
même pas encore énorme
bon enfin en tout cas
c'est
vous avez compris que je pensais que il
vaut mieux avoir un bon système des
règles de droit qui soit claire plutôt
que que d'avoir des mars qui sont qui
sont protectionnistes qui ne marche
jamais donc voilà donc je préfère pas
faire le droit appliqué à tous à
des démarches
cloud souverain je sais pas trop ce que
ça veut dire vous donner un exemple nous
nous nous effectuerons
pour le gouvernement chinois à hong kong
nous effectuons sur notre propre cloud
qui d'un cloud souvent c'est nous qui
les faisons nos systèmes nos logiciels
la comptabilité l'appelle le contrôle
d'accès en chine
les transports sur nos propres systèmes
cloud pour tous le gouvernement chinois
à hong kong voilà donc j'imagine c'est
un cloud souverain pour tenter une
société française qui le fait et croyez
moi qu on le fait avec des règles
extrêmement strictes et qu' il n'est pas
question qu'on ne se plie pas aux
régulations qu'on nous impose
voilà donc c'est une réponse à
au cloud souverain y compris dans des
pays
qui sont pour lequel ces questions sont
absolument
essentielles
ce que vous faites me semble c'est pour
ça que ce que vous faites me semble
absolument essentiel
alors
oui j'avais je vais écrire c'est depuis
ce que vous faites référence à cette
tribune que j'avais fait dans le monde
et avec les documents de sécurité du
reste parce que le titre que j'avais mis
de rester vraiment notre industrie des
télécoms brûle et nous regardons en
arrière c'était lorsque
le gouvernement précédent avait décider
ce qui est juste qu'ils mettent une
énorme erreur je lui ai dit du reste se
dissipant dans cette tribune c'est à
dire de troyer une quatrième licence
d'opérateur de télécommunications
mobiles
c'était je crois monsieur fillon qui
était premier ministre à l'époque et et
qui a permis à effectivement un
quatrième opérateur donc de saisir
l'opportunité qui est qui était offerte
pour
avoir un quatrième opérateur en france
tu ton que j'avais quitté tribune de
transition et télécoms brûle et nous
regardons en arrière paraphraser un
appel en république que j'ai servi aux
mêmes et
et c'est plus parce que dans le monde me
tribune s'est retrouvé sous le titre
free menace l'innovation en france je
sais pas quel hacker l'article vous avez
lu parce que je vois qu'il ya eu
mais c'était un article initial
effectivement m'ont proposé de tout
parler de free pour voter de parler du
régulateur même si effectivement il ya
en a bénéficié bon le sujet est assez
simple hélas je pense que la régulation
du secteur des télécoms dans son
ensemble que ce soit en france et en
europe a été une tragédie
je pense c'est une terrible erreur
on a une centaine d'opérateurs de
télécoms est évidemment en europe contre
2,4 aux états unis et trois en chine
alors bien sûr on va nous dire parce que
les lobbies sont très bien préparés les
dix ans tous mes collaborateurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux dont ces connais
bien
ah oui mais à quatre ou cinq opérateurs
on apprend on à 80 % de parts de marché
est très bien sauf que aujourd'hui on a
un système qui est totalement
destructeur de valeur et que nous sommes
il ya 20 ans
monsieur le sénateur lorsqu on
réfléchissait au bond de demain des
technologies d'information la france
était leader et l'europe et de leader et
la france je me souviens d'avoir été le
premier entreprenant de thomson à mettre
les premières expériences de télévision
sur adsl j'étais pris dans thomson
j'avais fait à l'époque avec certes
urique dans alcatel et martin bouygues
président de tf1 on est c'est en 99 on a
présenté les premières expériences de
thé de télévision sur adsl en europe je
me souviens en tant que besoin de france
télécom avoir déployé dans le cadre du
plan
donc qu'on a déployé sur l'ensemble de
l'ensemble du territoire national les
réseaux d les réseaux dsl pour permettre
d'avoir la télévision sur les réseaux
qui ont permis ensuite le triple play je
me souviens évidemment la france et
premier inventeur du gsm bon voilà donc
on a quand même des choses formidables
et puis aujourd'hui
notre industrie des télécoms elle sert à
quoi à financer la dette que des
personnes physiques ont contracté pour
pouvoir devenir l'opérateur d'un bien
public donc donc je vois bien que les
capacités aujourd'hui de financement je
juge sur les uns sur les autres c'est
notre système de régulation les
capacités de financement et
d'investissement que nous avons
créés dans ces dossiers télécoms sont
réduites comme peau de chagrin alors que
nous sommes avait à laval la veille une
vague absolument essentiel gigantesque
d'investissement
pour le haut débit dans les réseaux de
fibre pour la 5g on parle de la 5g
maintenant que les états unis la semaine
dernière tout le monde parle de la 5g
états unis vont redevenir un pays
extrêmement important en matière
d'investissement de les communiquer sur
leurs qu'il était complètement riec il
ya 12 ans lorsque j'étais plus en france
télécom
donc donc je pense qu'il est urgent de
revoir notre notre régulation ça n'a
rien à voir encore une fois pour les
acteurs des formidables entrepreneurs
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
entrepreneurs français je me fous de
respect pour iliad et free qui sont des
entrepreneurs je les dis qu'ils
saisissent les opportunités très
intelligemment
sfr s'est bien développé
wigan générer l'innovation notamment en
étant très rapprochées très rapprochés
avec docomo au japon pour essayer de me
créer les innovations à l'énergie qui
vont bien mais aujourd'hui force est de
constater qu'on a qu'on a un système qui
n'est pas du tout du tout adapté à nos
enjeux et donc
il est temps là on a essayé d'en parler
avec le régulateur nacira parlé avec
monsieur sidi kenny une admission
malheureusement j'avais été le ministre
avait portée
directe comme quand on a fusionné on a
créé l arcep avec
la feuille de route l'émission de
régulateur j'avais bien indiqué que dans
libé l'innovation et l'emploi je vais
pas moins le sentiment qu'il a oublié
l'innovation et l'emploi je pense qu'il
serait bien que le parlement le lui
rappellent
même site indépendant prie monsieur
c'est justement pour compléter votre
peau pour pourriez vous nous éclairer un
tout petit peu plus précisément sur les
contraintes que vous voyez peser
fortement sur nos entreprises dans le
secteur de ces nouvelles technologies
puisque vous avez été à la tête d'un
certain nombre d'entre elles non je
pense que vous avez pu bien identifiés
dans le cadre de notamment de la
concurrence mondiale au niveau européen
quels sont les les contraintes et puis
puisque vous avez évoqué l'arcep les
monsieur ainsi qu'annick nous avons
dissuadés ya pas si longtemps que ça
avec l'ensemble des présidents des
autorités de régulation tel que le csa
vous avez préconisé le rapprochement
cessa accepte
qu'on attendait vous comment voyez vous
qu'est ce qui justifie pleinement cette
fusion plus que ce rapprochement du
passé
on a déjà rapprochés iv la poste
moi je trouve que c'est à ça c'est quand
même assez près d assez proche des
télécommunications est au fond
je pense que
on va vers une concentration
indispensables des opérateurs de
télécommunications par la force des
choses on commence à lui dire
commencer à le dire en europe parce
qu'on est allé trop loin on va très vite
on va on va le dire en france
alors comme je connais un peu
l'administration
je pense que le travail des autorités de
régulation en france sur les télécoms va
un peu baisser ils vont avoir un petit
peu de temps je pense que c'est bien
qu'on concentre les deux
parler des données tout à l'heure il
s'agit finalement transfert de données
des données comme d'image pour le csa et
de sons sont sont importantes c'est un
des aspects des choses on va te prends
ce qu'on aurait tout à gagner comme
beaucoup de pays ils font du reste
désormais à unifier tout ça
voilà
l'autorité de régulation des
télécommunications
a accompagné
la transition d'un monde où tout ça
était sous contrôle étatique pour le
mettre un monde où tout ça est devenu
plus ouvert et libéral ce passage a été
fait il va maintenant vers une phase de
concentration des des acteurs
l'autorité de la concurrence a joué son
rôle dans cette affaire plus que la
recette du reste ne l'est pas du tout
entendu l'arcep du reste à les derniers
débats qui ont animé une partie du
secteur français au cours des dernières
semaines vous avez entendu revanche
l'autorité de la concurrence
donc je pense que soit très clair
ça ne va pas beaucoup moins de travail
là il va dire tout à fait le contraire à
cause de moi je pense qu'il va voir
beaucoup moins de travail à des gens qui
ont l'habitude de réguler un secteur je
pense que c'est bien de les mettre tous
ensemble et
dans la phase d'économie dans laquelle
nous entrons ce sera peut-être pas
inutile
bruit pays le font sur les contraintes
qui pèsent sur les entreprises au delà
des simples contraintes de régulation
je vais
je vais je vais
je je je n'ai pas l'habitude de
raisonner comme ça on est on est en
france on a nos propres aux contraintes
on a aussi le souplesse en abandonnant
il ya d'autres contraints dans d'autres
pays
voilà les contraintes spécifiques au
secteur des télécommunications au
secteur où ses toiles été collectés dans
lesquels j'ai pu j'ai pu travailler
elles sont plutôt liées à certaines
contraintes du droit du travail en
france at-on plutôt lié à la certaine
rigidité que nous avons voilà le le le
régulateur en france et moi lorsque
j'étais lorsque j'étais tête de france
télécom
le régulateur a fait un travail
d'accompagnement et de transition
puisque c'était la volonté à l'epo dès
17h aider les gouvernements de deux de
privatiser ce secteur de le rendre de
l'ouvrir il l'a fait avec tous plutôt
plutôt
d'intelligence même si évidemment par
définition pas d'être régulier quand
vous êtes le plus gros comme c'est le
cas de france télécom il faut lui
caresser pas c'est pas facile mais je
n'ai pas eu à les pommes de problème et
je trouve qu'il ya eu des dérives
effectivement ensuite quand on a voulu
allé beaucoup trop loin et notamment le
cas dans cette 4ème licence ça c'est
impressionnant vraiment un sujet je le
redis je le redit avec force sur les
contraintes font ça sont des contraintes
qui sont liés je pense à la spécificité
de droit du travail en france à la
spécificité aussi de notre
du système du système fiscal
vous avez beaucoup travaillé ces
derniers temps sur le système fiscal au
parlement beaucoup je lui dis le trigger
la radio et sa vie d'une émission pardon
et bientôt à la fin de ce
qu'il faut faire de publicité mais une
chaîne qui s appelle le vrai faux de
l'info est alors que j'avais indiqué que
c'était quand même terrible parce que au
cours du dernier quinquennat
il y avait eu une disposition fiscale
nouvelle par jour ouvré
je dis bien une disposition fiscale
nouvelle page ouverte on vous avez
beaucoup travaillé
malheureusement pour nous mais la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ça continue
j'avais été
effectivement une disposition fiscale
nouvelle page ouvrés entre 2007 et 2012
mais malheureusement ça continue depuis
2012 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc c'est
une contrainte un peu pour nous qu'il a
il faut s'adapter à tout ça on a
énormément d'admiration pour votre
capacité de travail mais des fois on ne
suit pas toujours
en deux mots vous pouvez nous nous
évoquer le projet lorsqu'il oui pardon
tout ceci pour vous dire que le vrai
faux de la foi avait dit mais tirait
votants raison il est peut-être même un
petit peu en dessous de la réalité voilà
c'est dit voilà le projet bluekiwi vous
pouvez nous en dire oui le bouquet
week-end moqueries des réseaux sociaux
oui on a on a lancé une initiative dans
le cadre de notre groupe on est 80
milles 180 mille ingénieurs chez à tous
évidemment j'avais constaté hier il ya
trois ans de cela que
nos collaborateurs passé beaucoup de
temps à envoyer des emails dans l'e-mail
est un instrument qui est un peu
archaïque en tout cas pour les embauches
à peu près de dix mille personnes à peu
près du village de leurs parents puis à
tous et donc on était jeune gourou qui
sortent des écoles qui sont des grandes
écoles que cette diversité pas
uniquement français vient à manquer
alors quand on leur donne les outils
travailler outlook pendant que faire de
la publicité ils n'ont jamais vue ils
travaillent sur les réseaux sociaux où
il travailla sur sur facebook sur
twitter surtout sa maman mais disons
donc on avait l'impression d'en donner
un instrument qui était quand même très
archaïque très linéaire hélas
cet homme
derniers emails reçus premiers emails
lus sans aucune autre critère de
sélection d'importance à voir des fois
contre les trésoreries c'est gagner un
petit drapeau rouge qui se bat côté vers
l'as raismes ans non seulement de la
sophistication donc c'est à ce moment
qu'ils sont quand même très très
archaïque est très lourd et donc très
contraignant parce que finalement
fait une analyse on a regardé mais
combien de temps passez vous sur vos
e-mails internes le sujet limal interne
l'externalisation extrêmement utile
c'est à quoi y électronique rapide en
interne on atteindra on a constaté que
nos collaboratrices et collaborateurs
passé en moyenne 16 heures par semaine
pour lire leurs e-mails internes
donc ça veut dire pratiquement la moitié
du temps de travail et alors c'est trop
demander videmment deuxième question
réalise bas combien sont utiles
15% entre 12 et 15% donc nous on est à
la recherche de la productivité ont fait
la productique comprendre la
productivité de l'innovation
technologique pour nos clients et donc
pour nous aussi donc c'est dit et du
confort aussi parce que il faut le temps
concurrence il faut écouter les médias
claude vient d'en faire mon travail qui
est agréable
et
et en fait donc j'ai décidé qu'on serait
la première entreprise au monde zéro mal
on s'est donné trois ans pour être
repris 0 mais les rebelles voulant dire
ça la belle
voilà donc on a en a on s'est lancé dans
un plan 0 email interne
et c'était il ya trois ans et
aujourd'hui donc on a pris donc on a
essayé de nous d'abord d'évaluer avec la
communauté scientifique que que dirige
enfin que coordonne plutôt eu des
retards dur puisque c'est moi qui la
dirige
oui parce que je pense qu'il est très
important que le patron dans une autre
prouesse technique soit le patron de la
recherche ou patrons j'ai toujours fait
ça chez france télécom c'est la même
chose chez thomson aussi même si
évidemment ils sont tous bien plus
computer point vous l'imaginez bien mais
enfin quand même c'est important que le
patron m'a dans les dents les aspects
techniques qu'on verse d'entreprise
technique
et donc donc on a en a on a ici de
chercher les technologies ça c'est
vraiment laid nos chercheurs nos
collaborateurs qui ont identifié quels
étaient les prix de technologie qui
pourrait nous permettre d'avoir d'autres
systèmes collaboratifs coopératif qui
permettent d'être un peu moderne quoi
fin donc on a identifié
et puis on a vu des entreprises
américaines tant pis france et c'est
finalement on a eu une petite start up
française qui s'appelait bluekiwi et
diffuser des outils collaboratifs donc
qui s'est substitué complètement à
l'e-mail et donc on a acheté cette cette
société on l'a réintégré chez nous on a
développé et aujourd'hui effectivement
on est trois ans après donc on a réduit
de à la fin les à 60%
d'e-mails en moins à la fin de l'année
dernière l'objectif c'est d'être à 80 %
du mail en moins homogène et on pense
que là on atteint le socle parce qu'il
fera toujours garder un nombre minimum
dit elle parce que par exemple quand moi
je m'adresse collaborateurs sa valeur
juridique donc là vous avez la lettre le
leem elle donc rien mais donc on n'y
reste pas un soc on pense qu'à 20% on
est très suivi par le gartner c'est une
première mondiale donc le gartner nous
suit et pensent qu'à 20% on a vraiment
le socle voilà on pourra pas descendre
plus bas on aura tout aux besoins de 20%
du mail classique mais on a maintenant
sur notre groupe on a plus de 3500
communauté qui qui travaillent en toile
il y avait du reste un article hier dans
les échos sur l'un de nos communautés
juridique tout aussi une première
mondiale qui s'appelle ils ont rappelé à
l'honnête je crois qu'elles sont
apparition bluekiwi
c'est absolument passionnant parce que
vous avez donc des sur votre écran vous
arrivez matin vous travaillez vous
travaillez en fait dans différentes
communautés marketing les juristes vous
travaille aussi sur des clips sur des
contrats donc sur un contrat on a
plusieurs là plusieurs fonctionnalités
donc il ya une communauté qui s'ouvre
sur un contrat et puis toutes les
compétences sont dessus
et vous voyez immédiatement ce qui se
passe c'est plus et plus de façons
l'abattement linéaire mais c'est au
contraire en fonction de l'importance en
fonction des sujets qui sont les vôtres
donc c'est un gain de temps absolument
extraordinaire et souplesse et une
facilité
c'est à travers le double ou bluekiwi
qu'on fait mais on fait aussi avec
d'autres outils comme sharepoint
et d'autres outils la messagerie
instantanée aussi la communication à
certaines positions sur les écrans pour
pouvoir se parler et puis éviter quand
même ne se parlait de nola de s'envoyer
un email quand on peut se parler tout
simplement y avait beaucoup choqué c'est
qu'on a des plateaux maintenant sur
lesquels on travaille je voyais un jour
je me promenais sur un plateau et
patron d'une équipe car ils vous faites
moi je dis bonjour à tous sa vérité sur
son ordinateur bonjour à tous mes sauts
ou sur lala lala peut pas leur dire
bonjour comme ça voilà donc si vous
voulez on arrive à un stade où on est
quand même on a une défense et et puis
surtout enfin en matière de qualité
parce qu'on est très très château sont
très sensibilisés à tous les
environnements qualité d'unique et il
travaille donc on aime
on chante on a été on a été sélectionnée
deuxième meilleur employeur de en france
après après eads donc c'est des choses
qui sont importantes pour nous et donc
quand on voit que que nos collaborateurs
passent deux ou trois heures parce par
jour ensuite en rentrant chez eux pour
aller voir comme ils disent aller faire
leurs e-mails ce qui vous arrive
évidemment vous faites la même chose
tout montré pareil voilà ça on pense que
là aussi il ya sans doute un moment un
débordement qu'il faut qu'il faut il
faut se réapproprier finalement la
technologie pour le faire voir leur
passe très très vite je m'excuse d'avoir
un peu monopolisé par
andré gattolin peut-être une dernière
question à poser
une également
merci madame la rapporteure oui vous
avez évoqué dans le début de votre
intervention la question effectivement 2
de la consommation énergétique indue de
claude et ça m'a mené une question où il
ya les questions de sécurisation du
cloud on parle de deux cyber criminalité
mais ça des doubles aussi le problème
non c'est à dire que si l'alimentation
du système n'est pas garanti ou qu'elle
est concentrée en certains endroits
stratégiques
est-ce que vous avez une réflexion en la
matière est ce qu'il ya des des modèles
qui sont envisagées pouvoir alors je
sais tout ce qui existe en matière de
sécurisation
du clown lui même mais comme vous le
dites enfin aujourd'hui la question qui
se pose où il centra nucléaire est
protégée est un objet cité et objectifs
objets objectif pardon stratégique si à
côté on met un autre objectif
stratégique
est ce que c'est bien des jouxter ou au
contraire il faut le regarder une
certaine un certain secret une certaine
discrétion parce que demain ça peut être
une source d'attac ou de déstabilisation
important on va peut-être prendre la
deuxième question comme ça vous pourrez
répondre
oui moi je vous ferai d'abord saluer
thierry et sa capacité prospective pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas j'étais un
stage
quand il était patron de thomson parce
que je voulais comprendre comment une
boîte qui était assez d eau aux coréens
pour 1 franc
trois ans après avait pu être
reconstituées et cd et est valorisé en
bourse à 100 milliards de francs ce qui
était quand même j'allais dire quelque
chose d'assez original pour mériter
qu'on s'y intéresse de seconde donc moi
je serai ces petits ma question et c'est
un peu en complément mais très
différents j'ai lu ces jours ci la
problématique énergétique du stockage
des données déclarées des data center
etc et c'est colossal c'est un enjeu
colossal et donc il y à des innovations
qui permettrait éventuellement de
récupérer
cette chaleur et de s'en servir
utilement plutôt que de là que de
consommer de l'énergie de nouveau pour
essayer de refroidir et donc est-ce que
c'est crédible
qu'en pensez vous ce etc et puis je
voulais juste ajouter un petit un petit
message publicitaire à l'attention de
tous dans l'aude nous sommes en train de
développer la régulation de l'énergie
par le stockage par volant d'inertie si
cette technologie vous intéresse avec un
taux de rendement extraordinaire
pas du département
alors pour la première pour la première
question
c'est évident que quand on le perd et ça
revient ça nous renvoie exactement au
travail que nous faisons opéré des
données est traité c'est pas anodin il
faut donc un certain nombre deux
éléments de régulation de qualité de
service voilà en d'autres termes
s'assurer par exemple qui a une double
boucle pour arrêter le pôle télécoms
dont
la trace n'est pas connue
avoir peut-être une
plupart du problème qu'on a du reste en
matière de traitement de données de
sécurisation c'est souvent parce qu'il
ya une pelleteuse qui arrache un câble
et qui fait sauter sauter une boucle ou
un câble électrique lorsque les travaux
à côté a pas cessé c'est bien souvent
les problèmes qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a
traité comme un traité qui va avoir des
conséquences très très importante donc c
est exactement ce type de réflexion que
nous avons voulu mener pour dire que
quand on opère des données il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments qu'il faut
c'est dont il faut assurer
double boucle sécurisation de la musa
suffisamment d'énergie même si votre
question va au-delà mais je vais y
revenir et puis aussi redondance
y compris la capacité ce qu'on a nous
dans tous deux gros datacenter et on
traite je peux vous dire le nom parce
qu'il est confidentielle il est secret
mais en traite des millions d'e-mails de
nos compatriotes de très très très très
loin donc on les traite on a des saveurs
dont on a des on a dû très très très
loin le premier
opérateur
en dizaines de millions d'e-mails
aujourd'hui on a des comptines et
consignes extrêmement strictes de
sécurisation y compris
en ce qui concerne l'alimentation
d'énergie y compris la capacité système
il ya le moindre problème de basculer
immédiatement sur des générateurs des
onduleurs et des générateurs nous avons
sur site avec nous avec d'autres fuel
qui est traité qui est mesuré et
contrôlé toutes les semaines pour éviter
que des particules this as propre qui
viennent le bloquer en finlande alors on
a décidé
d compte des contraintes de sécurité
d'exploitation qui sont extrêmement
sérieuse est-ce qu'on est simplement
c'est qu'il faut que tout le monde ait
les mêmes et puis il ya aussi la
redondance des sites
pour la quasi totalité des
infrastructures que nous opérons on a
deux sites à 6 à 7 en back up et quatre
enfants qui étaient complètement miroir
d'un autre et qui n'est évidemment pas
sur le même lieu que que le premier donc
évidemment il ya il ya tout ça
et je pense que aulas delà de 10 rebonds
basse et des sites ce qui doit être on
sécurise et qui doivent comme leçon de
sites stratégiques en france je crois
que si on commence à dire ce qu'on vient
de dire on va faire beaucoup de progrès
par rapport à peut-être d'autres qui
vont se dire ma tiens je me mets berges
de données je mets hébergeurs de web et
puis j'ouvre ça quasiment dans mon
départ dont un peu d'amour dans mon
garage et puis on y va et puis derrière
il peut y avoir pas ce moment des
applications de plus en plus sensibles
on opère nous les secteurs le secteur
bancaire on est le premier opérateur
européen en matière de paiement
électronique donc on opère pour des pays
entiers alors que la belgique est
quasiment entièrement opéré par nous on
a eu ce républicain on a eu un problème
il a
juste avant noël on a tous nos systèmes
je viens problèmes d'infrastructures si
son qui sont tombés et donc à les
commerçants 80 % des commerçants belges
qui utilisait les cartes de kalima
pouvait plus la veille de noël
en quelques heures un par quelques
minutes puisque en fait c'était une
heure vingt on a toujours fait basculer
sur un autre site qui était complètement
le miroir du premier et qu'il a permis
finalement de limiter voilà donc on a on
a servi vraiment ça arrive une fois tous
les dix ans d'arriver bien sûr mais je
dirais les opérateurs privés et en opère
des règles qui nous ont été fixés par
nos clients ou par parler je vous donne
pas les les contraintes que nous avons
quand on opère pour le gouvernement
chinois de hong kong des contraintes
extrêmement fier quand on opère pour les
services
français pour la défense
britannique pour la défense allemande à
des contraintes extrêmement strictes
donc on suit ces contraintes encore
faut-il qu'elles existent ce que nous
voulons dire c'est que désormais avec le
cloud vous pouvez mettre toutes sortes
de données des stratégies coude et non
stratégiques donc il faut probablement
on passe à ce système de régulation
de contrôle identique pour tout
simplement vous opéré par mode cloud
parce que vous ne savez pas ce qu'il ya
dessus il ya certainement des éléments
qui sont extrêmement sensibles et
précieux pour les personnes ou les
clients pour le compte desquels vous
vous opérez voilà et puis pour la
dernière question de sénateur adnot donc
si c'est certain que en matière
énergétique c'est l'adversaire viendra
non jeu absolument essentiel je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure
bon
parenthèse puisque tu as fait ton stage
chez thomson à l'époque pas le jour où
je suis arrivé chez thomson j'ai appelé
mon premier client qui était darty et je
lui dis je vous connais pas mais je
voudrais faire un stage chez vous il est
pendant une semaine alors président de
thomson je suis allé vendre des
téléviseurs g8 veste rouge thierry
stagiaires pour pouvoir apprendre
précisément ce qui se passe des
publicités secret je les payais comme
quoi les stages c'est dans les deux sens
à
voilà donc donc la question c'était sur
la sur l'énergie
est encore un peu plus sur leurs
agissements cette manière à pouvoir
facilement l'énergie est il et faire en
sorte que dieu les charges on en fasse
un profit c'est une c'est une c'est une
excellente question lors des groupes
comme schneider par exemple le font
maintenant beaucoup il ya effectivement
tout un champ de recherche puisque
évidemment ce qui coûte cher c'est le
refroidissement dans le dans le la
gestion des data centers
on a encore on est à la limite de la loi
de moore 1 par parenthèse donc ça veut
dire qu'on est on est maintenant au
coeur au coeur on peut pas réduire trop
maintenant la concentration des
processeurs qui sont intégrés sur une
puce compte tenu de l'échauffement on
est tellement proche de l'atome que
les chauffe mois devient absolument
gigantesque et ses essais le frein qu'on
commence à rencontrer justement la
militarisation donc de refroidissement
devient devient un enjeu absolument
essentiel mais je suis complètement
d'accord et un groupe pour moi le groupe
qui a le mieux intégré tout ça c'est
juste derrière électrique on travaille
dur est avec eux ils ont ils ont
énormément d'innovation c'est un sujet
c'est un sujet essentiel mais on voit
que cette question du refroidissement
est une question essentielle trouver les
économies on voit un certain nombre de
grands acteurs américains qui se disent
en nous par exemple on a data center qui
est extrêmement moderne qui tu as
en finlande
parce que précisément on a accès à des
refroidissements dans les fjords voilà
deux pour pour ensuite je fais les bills
par exemple par exemple voilà alors là
bon çà çà çà çà je je je sais pas je ne
sais pas si si ceux-ci
se demander des personnes qui ont pensé
en tout cas c'est passé ses premiers
mois les projets en tout cas c'est à
c'est un vrai sujet allait l'extraction
de la chaleur dans les datacenters et
donc la consommation d'énergie est un
sujet mais même des projets de barge
géante sur lesquelles on voit le fer
pour enfin briller projet mais on en
revient toujours une chose à partir du
moment où on double au double le nombre
de données gérées générés par l'humanité
tous les 18 mois et que fait unique une
première dans l'histoire humaine on les
stocke on peut les retrouver advitam
eternam
bah ça pose tout un tas de questions
physiques mais aussi morales et
politiques
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
échanges passionnants
il ya peut-être une question où on n'a
pas le temps de l'évoquer
malheureusement mais nous pensons que
les données c'est important mais aussi
la question de la neutralité du net qui
est un vrai sujet c'est à toute autre
question que je suis ça c'est
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais une
prochaine fois peut-être merci
voilà pour l'audition de thierry breton
l'ancien ministre de l'économie qui est
aujourd'hui le président d'atos géant
mondial de l'informatique on passe tout
de suite à l'audition d'olivier iteanu
qui lui représente isoc france
l'internet society france ils
s'intéressent notamment à la place de
l'europe dans la gouvernance mondiale
d'internet
bien d'écouter merci beaucoup d'être
assez maigre et remercie vous êtes
avocat la cour d'appel de paris vous
êtes professeur à paris lyon
l'enseigné étudié commenté le droit du
numérique je crois que votre
contribution va être très utile le
travail de cette mission bon je vous
laisse immédiatement la parole peut être
pour nous aider à mieux comprendre ce
que sont les enjeux juridiques du sujet
que nous traitons est obsolète pour
répondre à nos questions
disant merci donc effectivement je veux
qu'à depuis 25 ans
j'ai dédié mon activité au droit des
technologies de l'information dès
l'origine et pour peut-être préciser un
peu mon ma présentation effectivement
vous l'avais dit je suis chargé
d'enseignement eh bien ce n'est pas rien
à sorbonne en master de droit du
numérique puisque les noms sont
compliquées maintenant en politiques
publiques et propriété intellectuelle et
à paris aux endroits des communications
électroniques internes voilà dans un
master 2 qui est le seul en europe il
faut le savoir qui est dédié au droit
des télécoms voilà donc droit des
endroits de l'espace et les télécoms
c'est c'est le seul qui existe en europe
d'armes pareilles 11 et de ce point de
vue là toujours très très très en avance
voilà donc j'ai écrit à ses membres de
bouquins dont le premier droit français
en avril 96 qui s'appelait internet et
le droit j'ai pas trouvé à l'époque
d'éditeurs juridique je les fais chez
eyrolles que j'ai pas quitté depuis
donc la gouvernance puisque c'est votre
mission donc je les rencontre est
d'abord en ma qualité de président de
l'isoméride français disent 'ok france
de 2000 à 2003 et puis
ceci faisant cela parce qu'il ya quand
même une cooptation très forte puis on a
tendance à rechercher
nos amis américains dont on va
probablement parlé dans sa recherche et
ce qui a priori dans sont favorables de
là on m'a proposé j'ai suivi des travaux
de l'icann avant qu'elles soient créés
en 98 j'étais à berlin lorsque l'icann a
été créé à l'époque steppa l'icann
et j'étais d'ailleurs mission entre
guillemets commandé par le
cigref club informatique des grandes
entreprises françaises qui regroupe à
peu près 140 à 150 des plus grosses
entreprises françaises qui souhaitaient
s'intégrer dans le dispositif et que
j'ai pu faire désigner dans un de
travail puis j'ai été désigné dans un
comité statutaire de l'icann ce qui
était prévu dans les statuts qui
s'appelait de lattes large si tu te dis
committee qui donc était un comité qui
était qui devait réfléchir à la création
du lac large dont sébastien bachollet
ici présents a été représentant jusqu'à
encore il ya quelques jours je crois est
présent au conseil d'administration et
on nous étions deux européens désignés
vous savez qu'il dirige il désigne
partage le monde en cinq continents en
cinq parties et donc pour l'europe ya
toujours un européen du nord et du sud
et nous nous sommes rattachés l'ordre du
sud pourquoi pas et donc les européens
du nord c'était carl bild voilà donc
nous étions tous les deux
on n'a jamais vraiment plus par laisse
entendre qu'il y avait bon carl bildt
voilà enfin c'est ça s'est passé comme
ça puis ensuite j'ai été désigné dans un
comité statutaire et c'était la dernière
fois parce que sa demande il ya une
équation économique à résoudre quand on
est à dix câble parce que ceux qui sont
les cadres de fond priori que ça dans un
comité qui réfléchit c'est au devenir du
whois d'espèces d'annuaires cette base
de données
qui
évidemment suscite un certain nombre de
convoitises et j'ai par contre
démissionné en cours de comité parce que
effectivement c'était il y avait le le
responsable des noms de domaine facebook
ou 2 go daddy qui est un des premiers
des premiers unités enregistrement au
monde américaine ces gens là ne font que
ça et c'est des centaines de mails par
jour peut-être des dizaines quand même
et en réalité s'il très difficile de
pouvoir faire entrer ses idées dans ce
type de comité voilà donc moi j'ai
évidemment été très intéressés dans par
votre part votre mission nouveau rodez
nouvelle stratégie pour union européenne
dans la gouvernance mondiale de
l'internet je dirais que moi ce qui je
suis peut-être pas capable de répondre
sur la totalité des sujets qui me
concerne mais cette nouvelle stratégie
qui m'intéresse parce qu'effectivement
vous avez dû entendre ses discours on
incrimine beaucoup
le gouvernement américain
bon moi je voudrais quand même rappeler
tout simplement pour
depuis juillet depuis juin 2013 2 puis 6
et 7 juin 2013 on sait on connaît le
programme prisme
le programme prisme c'est ce sont des
entreprises qui adhèrent ce sont des
entreprises américaines qui adhèrent à
la première novembre 2007 microsoft la
dernière fin 2012 apple ils ont une
dizaine retrouve facebook google
je veux dire par là que incriminé le
grand américain c'est peut-être un peu
facile il y à il ya des véritables
enjeux que les entreprises américaines
ont compris et que peut-être les
entreprises européennes elles soient
n'ont pas compris soit ne peuvent pas
suivre et ça y est je crois que c'est ça
c'est ça l'enjeu je disais que lorsque
j'étais dans les comités de l'icann je
pouvais connaître quasiment à la seconde
le cours de la bourse concernant cisco
voilà c'est c'était pour dire que ce
sont des amériques des entreprises
américaines ont pénétré l'icann et c'est
peut-être ça le plus important problème
parce que on va parler des données à
caractère personnel bien sûr mais qui
est-ce qui surveille en réalité les
populations c'est pas la haine et ça se
sait google et facebook ce sont des
entreprises américaines qu'on a
autorisés à surveiller les populations
en échange de quoi casser ma vision des
choses on a
on leur a demandé de mettre la main si
vous permettez cette expression cette
image dans le pot de confiture des
données ses aînés ça mais ceux qui
collectent ces données ce qui surveille
et ceux qui font ce marketing prédictif
qui fait que nos vies sont sont suivis à
la seconde ça n'est pas la haine et ça
ce sont les entreprises américaines
alors tout ça m'amène à deux
observations
ce sera
j'espère mon apport à 7
à cette commission la vraie question
c'est comment faire émerger des
entreprises européennes me semble-t-il
c'est ça me semble t'il la stratégie
or de ce point de vue là j'ai une
proposition à faire à votre commission
une proposition de réflexion affaire de
commissions il ya deux grands
intermédiaires techniques
au travers desquels on est obligé de
passer pour pouvoir interpeller pour
pouvoir se soumettre au réseau
le premier s'appelle d'opérateur
d'opérateurs
ex de télécoms jusqu'en 19 jusqu'en 2004
en europe on parle et d'opérateurs et
télécoms puis les fournisseurs d'accès
internet ont rejoint la catégorie on
parle aujourd'hui d'opérateur de
communications électroniques et les
seconds va les appeler les hébergeurs
vous avez les opérateurs de
communications électroniques des
hébergeurs des premiers ou un statut ont
un statut qu'on retrouve dans le code
des postes et des communications
électroniques qui leur impose de se
déclarer auprès d'une autorité de
régulation nationales l'arcep en france
le défaut de déclaration étant puni
d'une peine de peines pénales à sertic l
39 du code des postes et communications
électroniques de mémoire ça nous est un
an et 75000 euros d'amendé on peut
importe il ya des peines pénales
associés ce statut c'est pas simplement
des formalités préalables obligatoires
c'est la soumission
jusqu'en 2003 un cahier des charges qui
prenait en compte les contraintes de
sécurité nationale parce que les
opérateurs de télécoms
ondées
ce sont évidemment des acteurs
stratégiques de dpi et qui aujourd'hui
ont un statut qu'on retrouve dans la
partie réglementaire du code des postes
et des communications électroniques dont
vous avez des opérateurs qui eux ont des
formalités préalables obligatoires à la
respecter à défaut de sanctions pénales
et qui ont un statut associer des
obligations vis-à-vis des consommateurs
visés de la sécurité nationale david la
défense vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de
deux d'obligations qui l'a aussi s'ils
font défaut à ces à ces obligations ont
le risque d'avoir leur leur déclaration
lors leur agrément leur leur statut
suspendu voire arrêter et puis à côté de
ça vous avez d'autres
intermédiaires en a parlé qu'ils
s'appellent les hébergeurs on en a eu un
qui vient de s'exprimer ici qui est la
société atos qui eux sont dans une
situation de effectivement de deux
niveaux concurrence complète total moi
ce que je remarque c'est qu'il me semble
que du point de vue de l'intérêt
national de la sécurité de la défense
il n'y a plus lieu de distinguer l'un et
l'autre d'ailleurs à terme il est
probable qu'on aura beaucoup de
difficulté de distinguer l'un et l'autre
celui qui offre l'accès au réseau soit
parce qu'il établit où il exploite des
réseaux soit parce qu'il offre de
service de l'accès réseau va être
difficile à distinguer de celui qui va
héberger des données et qui va les infos
gérer etc
or qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
voit donc des acteurs libres des
hébergeurs je pense à amazon par exemple
le numéro monde qui sont totalement
libres de fonctionner comme bon leur
semble comme bon leur semble qui
de surcroît souvent soumettre ceux qui
recourent à eux à une oie étrangères
regardez amazon
j'ai écrit sur mon blog récemment un
article qui dit que
internet est une zone de droit n'est pas
une zone de droit pour tout le monde
parce que dans à la fin des années 90
notamment vous avez un très bon rapport
du conseil de l'état conseil d'état qui
a été écrit par un pâle pierrotin vous
avez reçu tout à l'heure et qui a été
voté par l'assemblée générale où le
grand message était de dire elle avait
raison internet n'est pas une zone de
non droit
très bien ça c'est vrai que ça a été
c'est un apport important de ce rapport
puis ensuite c'est devenu un peu une
tarte à la crème mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire lorsque l'on à un citoyen
européen etc ont recours à google qui se
soumet aux américaines à facebook qui se
soumet à l'eau américaine à twitter qui
se souviennent américaine et amazon qui
se soumet à la loi américaine est-ce que
internet pour le citoyen européen est
une zone de droit dans ces conditions là
je crois que c'est difficile de répondre
positivement
et c est ce sont des des entreprises et
des services auxquels on a recours tous
les jours donc ces sociétés offre
s'adresse au marché français et
soumettent leurs leur relation plus
casser leur volonté après les juges
peuvent avoir des visions différentes à
des lois étrangères
donc on a ces gens qui ces sociétés ces
géants du web comme on les appelle
maintenant aujourd'hui qui ces
hébergeurs qui n'y sont sans statut
impose est obligatoire ce que je propose
sur laquelle jeu qui me semble être une
idée sur laquelle il faudra réfléchir
c'est que ces hébergeurs à l'instar de
ce qui se passe pour les opérateurs
épouse un régime statutaire qui est
pénalement sanctionnée lorsque il n'est
pas respectée dans ces formalités
préalables et dans c dans sa manière de
se comporter et vous pensez bien que si
demain un opérateur déclara l'arcep
osait
et pour se déclarer qu'ils font plus
avoir une présence physique en france
mais osait soumettre aux six clients à
nous arrêterons les noix étrangères
l'arcep tu as ta viendrait immédiatement
l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes à l'arrêt immédiatement donc
cette règle paraît simple en terme
stratégique parce que cet acteur là
c'est un acteur stratégique de
l'internet et il est non seulement comme
l'a dit sue breton à l'instant
le
détenteur des données de l'ensemble de
la population mais mais il ya encore une
fois un acteur qui est qui est
incontournable donc pourquoi ne pas
c'est une chose assez simple et ça
permettrait je pense à une
à une catégorie d'acteurs européens
d'émerger pourquoi ne pas imposer aux
hébergeurs eu la soumission à un statut
cetc c'est ce que je comptais vous
apporter comme message peut-être en
introduction avant qu'on échange sur sur
ces questions mais ça me paraît une voie
à explorer j'allais chalon jeu j'ajoute
de surcroît que ce régime existe déjà
pour des données de santé puisque vous
savez que en matière de données de santé
la loi impose aux hébergeurs un agrément
qui est délivrée par le ministère de la
santé et j'ajoute enfin que ce plan le
droit de la concurrence personne n'a
jamais trouvé a rien à redire au fait
que les autorités que les que les états
membres impose au niveau national
l'adhésion à un statut obligatoire et
pénalement sanctionnés lorsqu'ils n'est
pas respectée
donc ça me parait effectivement une
mesure radicale mais ne pas répondre
dans le contexte prisme à ce qui me
paraît être un tsunami quand même savoir
ce qu'on a appris de de la collaboration
entre ces géants du web et l'état
américain pour des motifs d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont
parfaitement légitime il s'agit de
lutter notamment contre le terrorisme ce
qui nous intéresse tous mais c'est quand
même tout de même la boîte noire
je rappelle quand même que le sénat
américain
votre votre correspondant lorsqu'il a
été question de de
reporter le patriot act de cinq ans il
ya des amendements côté déposé par des
sénateurs démocrates qui ont demandé des
garanties pour les citoyens et que le
sénat a refusé de les voter mais donc
cette demande a été présentée par un
sénateur américain voilà ce que je
voulais dire peut-être introduction
monsieur le sénateur et monsieur le
président
de ce que maintenant je suis je suis
disposition pour toute question
24 de votre votre mission voilà pour
l'audition de thierry breton on enchaîne
tout de suite sur l'audition d'olivier
et et anouk y avait également été
auditionnés par la mission d'information
sur la gouvernance mondiale d'internet
le président 10 oct france dit internet
society france avait notamment expliqué
la prééminence américaine en la matière